you want to know some scary [__] though
yeah they trained a language model so
like an AI on brain waves and basically
they would show people images people
just looked at the images they thought
about the images and the AI model
recreated what they were thinking
literally read the person's mind how
[__] scary is that I mean that's not
the did you just think about killing
someone
you're going to jail yeah this is
horrifying dude horrifying yep
horrifying the implications of this are
I don't even know what but they're so
vast I'm really glad everyone punched in
all like their ideas and thoughts about
the world into this [__] Jarvis
system yeah now it's just gonna third
eye know so much about us yeah
everything we're thinking